here is every enhancer in Hunter Hunter
ranked by how good they are at the
things the things being enhancement
usually thought of as the most boring in
Affinity yeah I I don't actually have
anything to follow that up but we are
kicking things off with Bill anime
Watchers may not be familiar with him
and manga readers May periodically
forget that he exists but he's an
enhancer and a very non-standard one at
that bill is a very rare support
enhancer with his ability being quite
simple it accelerates the growth of
living things which karapika is
currently abusing to its fullest to
accelerate the development of new nen
users in the succession War but Bill has
this ability because of his rather
frankly cowardly nature as he prefers
not to really fight battle himself hence
why he chose to guard a baby because he
thought that with the baby there would
not be any major conflict he was wrong
oh how wrong he was interestingly enough
completely counter to his nature bill is
actually part of Beyond netro's
Expedition team meaning that his ability
is in some way essential for survival on
the Dark Continent however bill is the
kind of enhancer who's only as good good
as the thing it is he's supporting or
more accurately he's only as powerful as
the person is who's using him and due to
this coin flip nature he's going smack
bang in the middle beat here because
he's neither horrible nor remarkable
he's just bill two things which cannot
be said of dog man our next enhancer who
was both horrible due to all of the
murdering he does and remarkable because
he is a dog man he is a pro wrestling
member of the Haley family and a current
level 36 under morena's game meaning
that he has potentially killed 36 people
like the rest of the family he is almost
certainly wildly inexperienced when it
comes to using Aura which would
ordinarily sent him straight down to the
detail however in dogman's case I will
make an exception Moreno's 36 Aura
boosts Elevate Dogman at least one level
beyond your classical nen chump so for
now Dogman will make his stand in C but
for someone quite literally incapable of
making a stand our next enhancer is
Guido the heavens Arena dude who
assaulted our main protagonist with
children's Amusement toys Guido is about
as basic as they come but to be Fair he
did beat gone but that's not uncommon
lots of people do that in fact it's a
club so large that the people who
couldn't be gone went on to become a far
more exclusive Society I do have some
sympathy for Guido I mean he had a
pretty rough what would the whole having
his lower body ripped off and everything
as his initiation to the world of Nan
nonsense it's not the best way to do it
sadly though sympathy does not equate to
Aura skill or competence hence why Guido
was ultimately defeated by a fellow
enhancer who had only learned that Nan
even existed a couple of weeks
beforehand and thus Guido is one
disappointing big old detail but have
you ever wondered what would happen if
you took all of the potential of Guido
and actually taught him properly well
what you get in that case is goto a man
with a similar enjoyment of enhancing
small objects but one that actually
stops to think about what he's doing and
much more importantly why he's doing
goto is a fantastic example of making
the best of what you've got because what
got us got in terms of aurum it isn't
much however what he lacks in Talent he
more than makes up for with hard work
and using his mind brain the fact that
he could apply his micro quantity of
Aura to present even a minor challenge
to hisoka is something exceptionally
praiseworthy and the only reason why
goto can't rank higher on this list is
due to the unfortunate limitations
placed on his talent however with that
said he did the absolute best he could
with what he had and he shall be
rewarded with an a tier for the somewhat
opposite now he is an enhancer with
infinite talent but a distinct lack of
intelligent application now I make fun
of gone a lot on this channel mostly for
his very basic air-headed ill-fated and
poorly thought out approaches to life in
general however that pretty much
describes the perfect enhancer because
it's an affinity that is very forgiving
of ideas that are well not particularly
well thought out gone is a stupidly
powerful enhancer and even though he
never came close to reaching his full
potential he in the span of less than
two years was able to outclass a whole
ton of fully grown adults who had long
reached their own comparatively low and
very sad limits bearing in mind that
this is not a tier list of the greatest
nen users in general it's a list of how
well enhancers perform at their affinity
and with that in mind gone is about as
close to a perfect enhancer as we can
reach and so he is an easy s tier now
for someone who is easily not that I
present Castro I legitimately love
Castro because he's a character inserted
into the series specifically to be a
tutorial of what not to do he's like a
living example of a textbook problem if
Castro and enhancer creates an inability
consisting of 50 conjuration and 50
manipulation then calculate how much of
a he is the answer being 100
because to put this bluntly Castro is
quite possibly the single worst example
of an enhancer and maybe even an end
user in general in this series he is so
terrible that I honestly believe that
putting him in the detail would be
insulting to those in that tier because
yeah those enhancers are awful ever so
awful but at least they're trying you
know that they're trying to enhance so
we're going to need to open up a very
special Castro tier just for this very
disappointing man now here's someone I
bet that most of you didn't even know
was an enhancer it's ikalgo and he was
very recently identified as an enhancer
by Yoshi hirotagashi himself through the
exhibition memo and although this comes
from the mouth of dog himself it does
raise a lot of awkward questions to be
straightforward it makes no sense and I
think that Togashi may not have been at
his very best when making this decision
mostly because he cargo's abilities are
entirely based in manipulation and
conjuration aka the two most unfriendly
affinities to him by far Living Dead
Dolls is pure manipulation and freedom
literally conjures bullets and I should
say that their cargo was labeled as a
manipulated in the data book which makes
sense but the authors were trumps that
and funnily enough the corpse of cargo
was most known for controlling flutter
also had abilities based entirely in
conjuration and manipulation and look
it's unfortunate for a cowga that we
have to do this but we have to judge him
as an enhancer and if he is indeed an
enhancer as tagashi says then he is one
very akin to Castro AKA pathetic and
choosing to base the entirety of their
ability sweet on their worst natural
affinities almost in denial about being
an enhancer which means that
unfortunately this octopus is getting
slapped with a Castro tear and now
here's where things get a little bit
hypocritical because our next fictional
character is Isaac natural a man who did
pretty much exactly what Castro and
icalgo did just much more better it's
debatable over whether netro uses
conjuration or a mission to construct
the statue of guanyin but what isn't
debatable is that he invests heavily
into manipulation to use it natural is
an enhancer who is strayed quiet far
from his natural path but look this this
just isn't fair because Isaac netro is
an example of an end user who has
transcended natural limits pushing the
art form further than any human we've
seen and by quiet of the gaping Chasm
his base Affinity almost doesn't matter
because he is just so far and above
everyone else that you would never be
able to tell that what he's doing is in
any way inefficient and to display that
we're going to open up an entirely new
god tier well above us Vanessa wrote
rather appropriately look down upon all
of the feeble masses one such feeble
mass of meat being comedy someone who we
recently Learned was actually an
enhancer in the memo alongside ikalgo
except that with comogy it makes a lot
more sense the super gungy ability might
look like a weird specialist power at
first but broken down it's essentially
comogy enhancing her mind to superhuman
levels in this one very Niche practice
with of course the insane self-imposed
restriction that if kamuki loses a game
she dies funnily enough comedy's
enhancement did what natural's
enhancement could not and actually
delivered a big fat L to the ant king
several fat juicy elves actually but
comogy is the quintessential example of
self-taught innovation redefining an
entire art form she is certainly
unorthodox but so successful that
comigee cannot be denied in estia moving
now to Maha zoldik and this is difficult
for quite a few reasons one the fact
that he's an enhancer comes from an
unreliable Data Book Two if this is true
then he's potentially an even greater
enhance of the netro and three we can't
even guarantee what his name is it might
not be Maha don't actually know that so
he's a he's a tricky thing to discuss in
general to make this as simple as
possible though if all of the above
information is true then I have no
choice but to place Maha in the God here
because regardless of how feeble he may
appear today Isaac Nitro was said to be
the only man to fight against Maha and
survive I'll say that again survive not
win survive implying that Maha was he
was quite something so until proven
otherwise he's going to sit rather
comfortably in his old man chair right
up around here finally hitting the
Phantom troop now it's Nobunaga a man
whose enhancement is so proficient that
throughout the course of Hunter Hunter
he's never even had to reveal his own
personal hatsu because his basic
enhancement is so damn good and precise
that he's not yet deemed it necessary
enough to do so and while we're here I'm
going to lump thinks into this
discussion as well because we have seen
his ability and rather typically for an
enhancer it involves a big old punch I
think that no binagar is definitely the
better precise enhancer but on the other
hand thinks is definitely the better big
punch enhancer which about balances both
amount out to me and as they are both
world-class criminals nen users it is
very difficult to award them anything
less than an S but for quite possibly
the most unique enhancer candidate
though we turn to Palm Siberia unique
because her ability like to this day it
is still completely unknown how it works
in terms of our use because I'll tell
you one thing it's not enhancement or
transmutation or conjuration or
manipulation or emission and apparently
it's not specialization either because
she is an enhancer but merman
Clairvoyance allows Palm to magically
stalk a Target after feeding a moment
Corp some delicious delicious Bloods
which I guess also casually confirms the
existence of merman in this world but
this should be a specialist ability it's
not but it should be after becoming a
hybrid ant however bomb does actually
embrace enhancement through Black Widow
a shockingly effective and devastating
suit of hair armor if this was pre and
palm she would probably rank pretty low
but post and palm now actually embracing
the affinity and with absurd Aura
quantities ripe for abuse is going to
sit pretty damn comfortably in the a
tier but as for some someone who gets
nowhere near that Prestige here is rabid
dog absolute garbage the dude enhanced
his teeth and tried to bite people and
they got surprised when it didn't work
oh my shitty idea didn't work no no
where did I go wrong still at least he
tried to use his Affinity so let's smack
rabbit dog with a big fat detail and
then continuing our journey into the
animal kingdom here is a strange rabbit
ant bird remote is another tricky one
because you know he's powerful but
nowhere near world class powerful and
he's dumb like really dumb but you know
not she too dumb so it's it's really
difficult to see where he sits I guess
in the end Vermont is the epitome of the
word mid as is his nenues and so he's
going to slot into the mid-tier of B but
you know there is someone who could only
dream of a bee and his name is orangey
we are going to deal with him swiftly
all he's done so far is enhanced copy of
weekly Shonen Jump so
couldn't even get the words out and
that's how disappointed I am in him and
the same goes for fellow Haley member
tevolares until proven otherwise D both
of you also as recording this I realized
my hypocrisy of putting dog man in sea
but those indeed but in my defense he is
a dog man and that automatically makes
him better on all fronts but for someone
slightly more proven and I only mean
slightly here is Wang an assistant
Master of the shingenriyu school of kung
fu who trained gone in kilua who were
also trained by biskey who also trained
Wings nice little training triangle they
have going on there but Wing himself is
a largely unknown quantity however given
his pedigree is a classically trained
nen boy under bisky I wouldn't be
surprised if he turned out to be an a
however that is a little bit too
speculative given the almost nothing
we've seen from wing and the almost no
achievements we've heard about him so
until he actually does something I'm
going to go with a bit of a safe B now
for everybody's favorite enhancer it's
Tron yeah the guy from the game called
Hunter Hunter each one's determination
an exclusive title for the Wonder Swan
color an ill-fated competitor to the
Game Boy that only sold 3.5 million
units I mean that is that's how old
Hunter Hunter is it has a title for the
Wonder Swan color with that said Tron
himself is a bit of a boss I mean quite
literally in the game he serves as a
boss but in the game not only does he
One-Shot karapika but he also agreed to
train karampika although his greatest
achievement definitely comes when he
convinces krapika to wear this very
pretty dress as a party disguise and
look as painfully non-canon as he is
Tron is a guy to be taken very seriously
within this particular Wonder Swan world
but also not too seriously if he were to
actually exist and to be clear none of
the hunter hunter characters actually
exist it's it's all fiction but if Tron
were to exist in this particular Cannon
fiction then I imagine he would be at
least whatever Wings level is so he is
going to be a solid B they're getting
much more serious we arrive at uvagin a
man who is typically thought of as the
ultimate traditional enhancer big
punches big body big body count and even
a big brain albeit mostly empty but
still like it like a physically big
brain and duvagin is an obvious easy s
tier although honestly he almost this
makes everyone in the St look a little
bit banned by comparison so let it be
known that uvagin is at the very least
the Undisputed punch king of s tier
however we have one last enhancer left
to rank and he has the potential to be
the most powerful enhancer of all but it
is a ho and therefore he is not zeppo
sucks I mean to put this guy into some
perspective kilowa said that he could
have beaten zeho without using them
that's how good zecho was not very so
into the D you go and that is every
enhancer in Hunter Hunter ranked
arbitrarily by a man on the internet